Grazie a tutti
Vabbè, allora
Ragazzi io non rifaccio la gag di dire ma vi rendete conto della responsabilità che mi caricate addosso
Però è come se l'avessi detto, perché
Allora noi in queste tre serate faremo tre lezioni che potrebbero sembrare lezioni di letteratura più che di storia
Però in realtà sono anche lezioni di storia
Incontreremo tre grandissimi scrittori o poeti russi del novecento
E il motivo per cui parliamo di loro è un motivo assolutamente egoistico
E che a me piacciono immensamente
E mi portano via il cuore
E quindi
Poi
Poi insomma voi vedete voi perché oggi ho anche incontrato qualcuno che mi ha detto
Allora finalmente stasera capirò perché il maestro e Margherita è un romanzo così importante
Che io non so mai riuscito a finirlo finora
Io non so se ci riesco e poi è questione sempre di gusti naturalmente
Però
Però stasera cominciamo raccontando la vita
Di Mikhail Afanasievich Bulgakov
L'autore del Maestro e Margherita
Bulgakov è nato nel 1891
A Kiev
Fino a sei mesi fa non ci sarebbe stato niente da dire in proposito
E avrei potuto continuare tranquillamente con la famiglia, l'infanzia, l'adolescenza
Invece oggi dobbiamo fermarci pochi secondi per fissare due coordinate
Nel 1891 a Kiev siamo nell'impero russo
In un impero multinazionale dove convivono innumerevoli nazionalità
E dove i territori non hanno delle identità etniche
Non esiste nessun luogo che si chiami la Russia
E non esiste nessun territorio che si chiami l'Ucraina
Dal punto di vista amministrativo sia chiaro
Poi in ogni zona il governo sa che lì vivono
Lì vivono più russi, lì vivono più ucraini, più ebrei
Ma non esistono ripartizioni amministrative precise
E nell'immenso impero la popolazione circola
E nelle grandi metropoli dell'impero come Kiev
La popolazione ovviamente appartiene a tutte le etnie dell'impero
E la lingua che si sente normalmente per la strada ovviamente è il russo
Mikhail Afanasievich è russo
Di famiglia russa, di lingua russa
È uno scrittore russo, anzi un nazionalista russo
Nato a Kiev
Come allora era normale
Era il primo di sette figli
Ah già che ce l'abbiamo
Lo vedete qui
Era il primo di sette figli di una famiglia agiata
Figlio di insegnanti e di preti e di religiosi
Sapete che nella chiesa russa i preti si sposano
Hanno figli
Ed è normale che ci siano famiglie di ecclesiastici
I dinastie di ecclesiastici
I nonni di Bulgakov sono tutte e due ecclesiastici
Sono tutte e due preti, sacerdoti
Il padre no, è un teologo però
E insegna storie delle religioni
All'Accademia Teologica di Kiev
La mamma è insegnante, anche lei
In una scuola femminile
I tempi sono quelli ovviamente
Il fatto che la famiglia sia una famiglia clericale
È un dato importante
Perché la religione
Non la chiesa
Che è del tutto assente
Ma la religione
Nel grande romanzo di Bulgakov
Ha un ruolo importantissimo
Bulgakov è un credente
In un paese che quando lui nasce
È un paese di credenti
E che invece per gran parte della sua vita
Sarà un paese ufficialmente ateo
Appartiene a quella generazione
Che è nata in quella che poi
Si è convenuto di chiamare la Belle Epoque
L'epoca bella
Bella perché nessuno si immaginava
Che cosa stava per succedere
La generazione di quelli nati nel 1891
Aveva un po' più di vent'anni
Quando è scoppiata la prima guerra mondiale
E fino a pochi giorni prima
Ognuno di loro aveva impostato la sua vita
E anche lui l'aveva impostata
Studiava medicina
La famiglia oltre che di sacerdoti
Era una famiglia di medici
Aveva due zii materni medici
Che poi l'hanno anche aiutato nella carriera
E quindi Bulgakov studia medicina
Da ragazzo di buona famiglia
Che ha dei mezzi
Che se la cava tranquillamente
Le fotografie lo mostrano
Appunto
Quelle ancora più giovanili
E ancora più un elegantone col papillon
In certe fotografie col monocolo
Sempre la sigaretta in bocca naturalmente
Quando scoppia la guerra del 14
La grande guerra
Si era appena sposato
Con la sua prima moglie
Tatiana
Ne ha avute tre di mogli
Non doveva essere un uomo facile
E Tatiana
È vissuta fino a 90 anni
E noi abbiamo i suoi ricordi
Abbiamo i ricordi di questo matrimonio
Con questo giovanotto
Studente in medicina
Di buona famiglia
Però non è che i soldi
Ecco
Uscissero proprio da tutte le parti
Anzi
Perché dice Tatiana
Micael
Era uno spendacione
Non era mica capace di fare economia
I soldi arrivavano e uscivano
I genitori ci aiutavano
Però dice Tatiana
In quei primi anni
In quei primi tempi del matrimonio
Tante volte non c'era un soldo
Non c'era un rublo
Tatiana
Andiamo a pranzo dalla mamma
Ma si accorge che non ho più l'anello
E la catenina
Ecco
Tutto dallo strozzino
Scoppia la guerra
La guerra che in tutta Europa
Travolge tutti
In un'orgia di entusiasmo nazionalista
Che oggi è difficile da immaginare
Con i ragazzi che vanno ad arruolarsi volontari
Micael si arruola
Si arruola volontario
E uno studente in medicina
Si arruola come studente
Come assistente medico
Nella croce rossa
Dell'esercito dello zar
Presta servizio al fronte
Intanto continua a studiare
Alla fine del 1916
Si laurea in medicina
E viene congenato dall'esercito
Perché anche di medici
C'è un gran bisogno
Nell'impero
Un dettaglio della vita di Bulgakov
Di quegli anni
Su cui non si è fatta mai molta chiarezza
E che a un certo punto comincia a prendere la morfina
E nei documenti
Nelle testimonianze che abbiamo
Non è chiarissimo il perché
Perché qualcuno parla di una ferita in guerra
Molto dolorosa
Altre testimonianze dicono
Ma no, no, non è mai stato ferito
Non è mai stato neanche al fronte
In realtà
Lavorava in ospedale
Era un'allergia
Di sicuro c'è che per un po' di tempo
Prende la morfina
Poi riesce
Riesce a togliersi da questa cosa
Congedato dall'esercito
Torna a Kiev
E apre un ambulatorio
E un medico
E specialista in malattie venere
Fa appena in tempo a cominciare
Dalla guerra
In Russia
Si passa direttamente alla rivoluzione
E alla guerra civile
Alla guerra civile
Che in Ucraina
E a Kiev
È particolarmente complicata
Perché in tutto il paese
Si affrontano fondamentalmente
I rossi e i bianchi
I bolshevichi
Che hanno fatto il colpo di Stato
A ottobre
E hanno preso il potere
E i bianchi
Cioè gli zaristi
Quelli che sono fedeli allo zar
E vorrebbero tornare
Ai vecchi tempi
A Kiev è più complicato di così
Perché ci sono anche gli ucraini
Ci sono gli ucraini
Che sotto l'impero degli zar
Erano considerati come
Una variante dei russi
Un tipo di russi
C'è una zona dove i russi
Parlano una lingua diversa
E hanno tradizioni diverse
Il loro folklore è un po' diverso
Sono sempre russi anche loro
Di un altro tipo
Ma in Ucraina c'è anche invece
Un movimento indipendentista
Che afferma un'identità ucraina
E quindi a Kiev
A Kiev la guerra civile
È particolarmente complicata
Perché non ci sono solo i bianchi
E i rossi
Ci sono anche i nazionalisti ucraini
Che prendono il potere
Poi sono sconfitti dai bianchi
E i bianchi occupano Kiev
In nome dello zar
E poi arrivano i rossi
E prendono Kiev
In nome della rivoluzione
Poi tornano gli ucraini
In nome dell'Ucraina indipendente
E in questo contesto
In questa città
Alla fame ovviamente
Alla fame e al freddo
Dove ogni pochi mesi
Arriva un nuovo esercito
Che assedia la città
E la conquista
E il dottor Bulgakov
Essendo un dottore
È molto richiesto
Perché tutti questi eserciti
Hanno bisogno di dottori
E quindi
E quindi lo prendono
E se lo portano via
Ed è costretto
A prestare servizio
Anche se non ha voglia
In uno o nell'altro
Di questi eserciti
Beh chi di voi
Ha letto il dottor Zhivago
O ha visto il film
Del dottor Zhivago
Sa che lì
Lì Pasternak
Ha raccontato proprio
Una cosa simile
Il suo protagonista
È un medico
E lo prendono
Se lo portano via
Per forza
Perché
Perché hanno bisogno
Di medici
Certo è che Bulgakov
Pur prestando servizio
Per quelli che comandano
In quel momento
Però le sue idee
Le ha
E chiarissime
Lui sta coi bianchi
Lui è coi bianchi
È con lo zar
E
Il servizio
Su cui siamo meglio informati
Lo presta
In un reggimento
Cosacco
Dell'armata bianca
Che è impegnato
Anche nel
Caucaso
In operazioni
Contro i montanari
Musulmani
Del Caucaso
Perché è già complicato
Allora quel mondo
Mica solo adesso
Con i ceceni
Ecco
E anche i suoi fratelli
Sono ufficiali
Dell'armata bianca
E poi la guerra civile
Finisce
E i bianchi
Perdono
E l'armata bianca
Viene sciolta
E quelli che possono
Scappano all'estero
E tutta la famiglia
Di Michaela
Fanasevich
Scappa all'estero
E lui no
Perché nel Caucaso
Si è preso il tifo
E quindi è bloccato
In ospedale
E quando guarisce
Ormai è tutto finito
Gli altri sono scappati
E lui è lì
In Unione Sovietica
E a questo punto
Decide di mandare
Al diavolo
La medicina
E di fare
Quello che in realtà
Ha sempre avuto voglia
Di fare
Cioè
Scrivere
C'è una lettera
Del primo febbraio
Al fratello
A Parigi
Credo
Ho rimandato
Per quattro anni
Quello che avrei dovuto
Cominciare a fare
Già da un pezzo
Scrivere
Scrive
Scrive racconti
Pubblica
Scrive per il teatro
Soprattutto
Qui dobbiamo
Aver presente
Una cosa
Che nel nostro mondo
Oggi è morte e sepolta
Il teatro
Allora
Anche da noi ancora
Ma credo
In Russia
Ancora di più
Il teatro
Era una cosa
Popolarissima
I teatri
Erano sempre
Strapieni
Si andava in scena
Tutte le sere
E i giovani letterati
Che volevano
Aver successo
Scrivevano teatro
Scrivevano drammi
Piesi
Come si dice in russo
Bulgakov
Scrive per il teatro
Riesce a farsi
Mettere in scena
In diverse città
Di provincia
E poi però
Poi nel dicembre
Del 1921
Si trasferisce
A Mosca
Perché la Russia
È uno di quei paesi
Dove fra la capitale
E tutto il resto
Del paese
C'è un abisso
E tutto quello
Che conta
È concentrato
Nella capitale
Il livello culturale
Il livello di vita
È tutta un'altra cosa
Rispetto alla provincia
Immensa
Era così allora
In qualche misura
Credo che sia così
Anche nella Russia
Di oggi
Certamente allora
Era così
Chi vuole avere
Veramente successo
Deve andare a Mosca
Avete presente
Chekhov
No?
Le tre sorelle
A Mosca
Ecco
Bulgakov
Nel dicembre del 21
Si trasferisce
A Mosca
Con Tatiana
E ci vivrà
A Mosca
Tutti gli anni
Che gli restano
Che non sono tantissimi
Anche se
Tutta la sera
Parleremo di quel periodo
Poco più di vent'anni
No neanche
Neanche vent'anni
Vivrà
A Mosca
Mikhail
Afanasievich
A Mosca
Fa lo scrittore
Scrive sui giornali
Scrive articoli
Scrive racconti
Scrive pezzi
I pezzi di costume
Quelli che in russo
Si chiamano
Feietoni
I feieton
Sono i pezzi di costume
Che sui giornali russi
Sono sempre popolarissimi
E pian piano
Pian piano
Intanto la guerra civile
È finita
I rossi hanno vinto
L'unione sovietica
Si è stabilizzata
Anche se nessun paese
Straniero
La riconosce
E la vita intellettuale
A Mosca
È vivacissima
Si fa cinema
Si fa grafica
Si fa teatro
Si fa poesia
In apparenza
Un'incredibile libertà creativa
E anche in realtà
Però al tempo stesso
Comincia anche
La burocratizzazione
Della vita culturale
Lo stato sovietico
Vuole sapere
Cosa succede
Vuole organizzare
Vuole controllare
Nasce
L'unione
Degli scrittori
E Bulgakov
Nel 23
Entra
Nell'unione
Degli scrittori
Vanno avanti
In parallelo
La vita
Pubblica
Dello scrittore
Dell'uomo di teatro
E la vita privata
Nel 24
Divorzia
Da Tatiana
Che appunto
Vivrà fino a 90 anni
Gli sopravviverà
Di tanto
Tanto tempo
E avrà modo
Di raccontare
In un altro mondo
Ormai
In un'altra epoca
Di raccontare
Di quegli primi anni
Sposa la sua seconda moglie
Lyubov
Che in russo
Vuol dire
Amore
Anche Lyubov
Vivrà fino a 92 anni
E pubblica
E comincia
E comincia a scrivere
Anche qualcosa
Di più importante
Romanzi
In particolare
Scrive un romanzo
Che si intitola
La guardia bianca
È il termine
In cui
In gergo sovietico
Si indicano
I bianchi
Appunto
Zaristi
I rossi
Sono le guardie rosse
E i bianchi
Sono le guardie bianche
E Bulgakov
A Mosca
A metà degli anni venti
In unione sovietica
Pubblica un romanzo
I cui protagonisti
Sono gli ufficiali bianchi
Come i suoi fratelli
Anzi
Uno dei protagonisti
È uno di questa famiglia
C'è una famiglia
Di fratelli
I turbin
Nobili
Ufficiali
Uno di loro
È un medico
Specialista in malattia
Venere
E la guardia bianca
Racconta appunto
Di questa famiglia
Che nella sfacelo
Della Russia
In rivoluzione
Ostinatamente
Continua a difendere
Questo mondo
Morto e sepolto
Dello zar
Ovviamente non è che
Nella mosca sovietica
Di metà anni venti
Le autorità
Siano entusiaste
Di un autore di teatro
E di romanzi
Che pubblica libri
In cui i protagonisti
Sono gli ufficiali bianchi
Per cui
Per cui comincia a avere
Dei problemi
Scrive anche un dramma
In cui parla appunto
Del dramma
Dei bianchi
Della loro
Immigrazione
La fuga
Si intitola
Quello non glielo
Mettono in scena
I responsabili
Trasmettono un rapporto
Alle alte sfere
In cui spiegano
Che questo dramma
Di Bulgakov
Non è mica il caso
Di metterlo in scena
Glorifica
L'emigrazione
Quelli che sono scappati
E i generali bianchi
Risultato
Inevitabilmente
La polizia politica
Comincia a interessarsi
Di lui
La polizia politica
Che negli anni
Della rivoluzione
Si chiamava la CECA
La commissione straordinaria
E che poi
Cambierà nome
Parecchie volte
Adesso negli anni venti
Si chiama la GPU
Nel 1926
La GPU
Fa una perquisizione
A casa di Bulgakov
A Mosca
Gli sequestrano
Il diario
E il dattilo scritto
Di un romanzo
Che si intitola
Cuore di cane
In cui si racconta
Di uno scienziato
Che al giorno d'oggi
Nella Mosca sovietica
Uno scienziato geniale
Assolutamente
Re azionario
Anticomunista
Ma siccome è un grandissimo medico
E i capi si curano da lui
Fa tutto quello che vuole
Vive in un grandissimo appartamento
Se qualcuno gli rompe le scatole
Si attacca al telefono
Quando arriva il capo
Il capo fabbricato
Proletario
A protestare
Perché il dottore da solo
Occupa sei stanze
Mentre gli altri
Stanno tutti
Due famiglie
In una stanza
Com'è che il dottore
Occupa sei stanze
Ne deve cedere qualcuna
Il dottore dice
In effetti avevo intenzione
Di chiederne una settima
Perché sei non mi bastano
E quando il capo fabbricato
Minaccia
Denunce
Proteste
Il professore
Prende il telefono
Dice
Passatemi un po' il cremlino
Già
Un nome qualunque
Buongiorno
Senta
La sua operazione
Devo rinviarla
Perché qui ho dei problemi
Con l'alloggio
Lo scienziato
Non ha un problema
Al mondo
E trapianta
Fa un trapianto di cuore
Mirabolante
Trapianta
Il cuore di un cane
In un malato di cuore
Con il risultato
Che col tempo
Il malato
Che apparentemente guarisce
L'operazione riesce perfettamente
Poi pian piano
Il malato
Comincia a trasformarsi
In cane
Questo è il romanzo
Che Bulgakov
Aveva appena terminato
Quando la GPU
La polizia politica
Perquisisce casa sua
Gli confiscano il romanzo
Gli confiscano il diario
Il romanzo
Finisce direttamente
Sul tavolo del capo
Della censura
Pavel Ivanovich
Liebedev Poliansky
Il quale
Fa rapporto
Al comitato centrale
Del partito
Dichiarando
Che questo romanzo
Di Bulgakov
È chiaramente
Controrivoluzionario
Ora vorrei farvi notare
Una cosa
Che quando parliamo
Di queste vicende
Sembra sempre ovvia
La Russia è piena
Di scrittori
Di poeti
Di drammaturghi
Il comitato centrale
Del partito
Che dirige
L'unione sovietica
La vita economica
La politica estera
Di questo immenso impero
Si fa fare
Un rapporto
Sul romanzo
Che è stato
Confiscato
A casa
Dello scrittore
Bulgakov
Vogliamo sapere
Cosa sta scrivendo
Perché
Per disgrazia
Di tutti questi scrittori
Il potere sovietico
Dà agli scrittori
Un'importanza
Immensa
Alla parola scritta
E alla parola stampata
Si dà
Un'importanza
Gigantesca
E quindi
Di ogni parola
Il potere
Vuole essere informato
Il romanzo
Non si pubblica
Il diario
Dopo un po'
Glielo restituiscono
Bulgakov
Avendo capito
L'aria che tira
Brucia
Il diario
E non ne terrà
Mai più uno
Avendo imparato
Dopodiché
Noi il diario
Che lui ha bruciato
Naturalmente
Ce l'abbiamo
Perché la GPU
Prima di restituirgli
Non aveva fatto
Una copia
E dopo la caduta
Dell'unione sovietica
Gli studiosi
Sono andati in folla
Negli archivi
Del KGB
Come ormai si chiamava
La polizia politica
E hanno trovato tutto
E quindi hanno trovato
Anche il diario
Che Bulgakov
Aveva bruciato
Continua a lavorare
La polizia
Però lo tiene d'occhio
Ogni tanto
Lo convocano
In una convocazione
Sempre nel 26
Abbiamo il verbale
Gli dicono
Ma lei
Non è mica
Tanto favorevole
Al potere sovietico
Vero
E Bulgakov
Testualmente
Ma in passato
Non lo ero
Nelle mie prime opere
Avevo un atteggiamento
Critico
Negativo
Verso la Russia sovietica
La mia simpatia
Era totalmente
Dalla parte
Dei bianchi
Ora
Voi sapete
Che nel corso
Degli anni venti
In un'unione sovietica
Si combatte
Una lotta di potere
Senza
Esclusione di colpi
C'è una progressiva
Chiusura
E c'è il progressivo
Trionfo
Di uno
Dei concorrenti
Per il potere supremo
Stalin
Il quale
Progressivamente
Liquida i suoi avversari
E si impone
Come unico
Padrone
Lo chiamavano proprio così
A un certo punto
Era diventato normale
Fra i suoi collaboratori
Chiamarlo così
Hasein
Il padrone
Stalin sta diventando
Dell'unione sovietica
E Stalin
Vuol sapere tutto
Vuol tenere d'occhio
Tutto
Gli scrittori
E i poeti
Perché attribuisce
Anche lui
Personalmente
Una enorme importanza
A quello che fanno
E scrivono
Gli scrittori
E i poeti
E con l'ascesa
Di Stalin
Al potere
Diventa
Fondamentale
Nella vita
Di Bulgakov
Il rapporto
Con Stalin
Che è un rapporto
Assolutamente
Surreale
Un rapporto
Con questo potere
Malvagio
Responsabile
Di tragedie
Spaventose
E che però
Al tempo stesso
È anche un potere
Capace di intervenire
A cambiare
La vita
Della gente
In modo assolutamente
Imprevedibile
Capriccioso
Quando parleremo
Del grande romanzo
Di Bulgakov
Il maestro e Margherita
Vi dirò che
Il vero protagonista
Del romanzo
Chi l'ha letto
Lo sa
È il diavolo
Satana
È nel diavolo
Che Bulgakov
Raffigura
Nel maestro e Margherita
La potenza
Del male
Che però
Interviene
Nella vita
Della gente
In modi sorprendenti
A volte
Per raddrizzarla
Ecco
È difficile
Non intravedere
Stalin
Bulgakov
A forza di scrivere
Storie di ufficiali
Bianchi
Era finito
Decisamente
In disgrazia
I direttori
Dei teatri
Non avevano più
Voglia di mettere
In scena
Le sue opere
Poi finalmente
Ne mettono in scena
Una
Al teatro
D'arte
Di Mosca
Che è uno
Dei più importanti
Teatri del paese
Va in scena
Un dramma
Che Bulgakov
Ha pensato bene
Di trarre
Dal suo romanzo
La guardia bianca
Si intitola
I giorni dei Turbin
E racconta
Con toni nostalgici
La vita
Di questo gruppetto
Di nobili
Ufficiali
Uno è un medico
Appunto
A Kiev
Che tentano
Disperatamente
Di combattere
Per il vecchio mondo
Che sta venendo
Spazzato via
Ora
Apparentemente
Allora
Se fossimo ingenui
Diremmo
Figurati se lo mettono in scena
Un dramma così
A Mosca
Nel 1926
Ma la realtà
Era molto più surreale
Di quello che noi possiamo credere
Perché la realtà
È che per mettere in scena
Questo dramma
Si discute
A Mosca
Al massimo livello
Il ministero
Per l'educazione
Però non si chiamavano ancora
Ministeri
Sapete che nei primi anni
Della rivoluzione
I ministeri si chiamavano
Commissariati del popolo
Ed erano tutti chiamati
In sigla
Il ministero dell'educazione
Si chiamava
Il Narcompros
Al ministero per l'educazione
Autorizzano
La rappresentazione
Del dramma di Bulgakov
Il giorno dopo
La GPU
La polizia politica
Fa sapere
Che lei è contraria
E quindi
Va tutto a monte
Una settimana dopo
Ne discute
Il politbureau
Cioè
L'ufficio politico
Del partito comunista
Il governo
Del paese
E Stalin
In persona
Interviene
Dicendo
Sì vabbè
Destra
Sinistra
Quando uno scrittore
È così bravo
È inutile chiedere
Di che partito è
E i giorni dei Turbin
Va in scena
Al teatro d'arte
Di Mosca
E la leggenda
Che gli intellettuali russi
Si tramandano
Da sempre
È che Stalin
Va a vederlo
15 volte
Le ricerche più recenti
Dicono che non c'è la prova
Che si è andato 15 volte
Però ci è andato
Di sicuro
Più di una volta
Bulgakov
A Stalin
Piace da matti
E questo dramma
Che parla dei bianchi
Intendiamoci
Bulgakov
Non è del tutto stupido
Lui raffigura
Questi bianchi
A Kiev
In un momento
In cui l'armata bianca
Sta collassando
Non sotto l'impatto
Dei rossi
Ma sotto l'impatto
Dei nazionalisti ucraini
Dell'esercito nazionale
Ucraino
Di Petliura
Che fra un massacro
Di ebrei e l'altro
Sta prendendo
D'assalto Kiev
Difesa dai bianchi
Ecco
Fatto sta
Che Stalin
C'è anche un'occasione
Nel 29
In cui
In un incontro
Con gli scrittori ucraini
Stalin dice
No no
Effettivamente
Questo dramma
Di Bulgakov
È un dramma
Antisovietico
Bulgakov
Non è dei nostri
Ma quando
Nel gennaio del 32
Mi porto un po' avanti
Quando nel gennaio del 32
Il direttore del teatro
D'arte di Mosca
Per un eccesso di zelo
Decide di togliere
Dal cartellone
I giorni
I giorni dei turbin
Stalin
Una sera
Va a teatro
Ci andava tutte le sere
Vede un'altra commedia
Poi dice al direttore
Dice ma una volta
Davate un bel dramma
I giorni dei turbin
Come mai
Non lo date più
È un bel dramma
Bisogna darlo
Datelo
Il giorno dopo
Il dramma
È in scena
E non viene mai più
Tolto dal cartellone
Dopodiché
Stalin ovviamente
Aveva anche altro
A cui pensare
La fine degli anni venti
Sono gli anni
Della grande svolta
Della collettivizzazione
Forzata
Dell'introduzione
Dei colchossi
Nelle campagne
La confisca
Delle terre
E del bestiame
Ai contadini
La guerra civile
Nelle campagne
La fame in Ucraina
Sono anni terrifici
Il primo piano
Quinquennale
Di tutto questo
A Mosca
Probabilmente
Uno che vive a Mosca
E vuole fare lo scrittore
Vuole fare l'uomo di teatro
Vuole mettere in scena
Le sue opere
Probabilmente
Se ne accorge
Fino a un certo punto
Di tutto questo
Il problema è però
Che appunto
Stalin ha altro
A cui pensare
E tanti
Hanno messo gli occhi
Su Bulgakov
Come uno
Che appunto
Non è dei nostri
E quindi
Diventa sempre più difficile
Mettere in scena
I suoi drammi
E se non metti in scena
Niente
Non guadagni neanche niente
Naturalmente
E non solo
Come succede
Quando in quel mondo
Di letterati
Dove tutti stanno
Ben attenti
A vedere
Da che parte
Va il potere
Oscilla la fortuna
E quando si comincia
A capire
Che Bulgakov
Non è più
Tanto protetto
Tanto garantito
Allora ci sono anche
Quelli che cominciano
A denunciarlo
A scrivere
I collettivi di attori
Che scrivono
All'autorità
Dicendo
Ma questo drammaturgo
È antisovietico
In realtà
Basta
Non mettetelo
Più in scena
Alla fine
Non c'è più niente
Di suo in scena
Nel 1930
Esce una grande
Enciclopedia letteraria
In Unione Sovietica
E l'enciclopedia letteraria
Del 1930
Dedica
Una lunga voce
A Bulgakov
Molto dettagliata
Piena di informazioni
Che dice
Che è uno scrittore
Interessante
Però
Non è dei nostri
Appunto
Appartiene
A un'altra classe sociale
A un altro mondo
Cito
Dall'enciclopedia letteraria
Del 1930
Voce
Bulgakov
Mikhail Bulgakov
Non è riuscito
Né ad apprezzare
La morte
Del vecchio
Né a capire
La costruzione
Del nuovo
Certo
Si è rivolto
Alla letteratura
Con la coscienza
Della morte
Della sua classe
La vecchia borghesia
La vecchia aristocrazia
Zerista
Certo che lui
Ha capito
Che è morta
Ma non ha preso
La vittoria
Del popolo
Con gioia
Ma con dolorosa
Rassegnazione
Tutto il percorso
Artistico
Di Bulgakov
E il percorso
Di una persona
Ostile
Per appartenenza
Di classe
Alla realtà
Sovietica
E Bulgakov
Nella primavera
Del 1930
Distrutto
Dalla totale
Ostilità
Di tutto il mondo
Letterario
Dall'impossibilità
Di pubblicare
O di mettere in scena
Le sue cose
Scrive una lettera
Al governo
Sovietico
In cui denuncia
Con un tono
Quasi isterico
La persecuzione
Di cui da anni
È vittima
Bulgakov
Scrive questa lettera
Che è pubblica
E si trova
In internet
Dice
Ho una cartella
Con tutti i ritagli
Di stampa
Che mi ha dedicato
La stampa sovietica
In dieci anni
Di attività letteraria
Sono 301 articoli
E di questi
Tre
Sono elogiativi
Ostili
E insultanti
E cita
Cita questi articoli
Di critici sovietici
Che dicono
Questa vecchia puttana
Della aristocrazia
Zerista
Quest'uomo
Di un passato
Morto
Sepolto
Che non ha più
Nessun motivo
Di esistere
E alla fine
Di questa sua lettera
Dice
Ho mi dato un lavoro
Ho mi lasciato
Andar via
Io mi rivolgo
All'umanità
Del potere sovietico
E chiedo
Che a me
Scrittore
Che non posso essere utile
Qui da me
In patria
Magnanimamente
Si è concessa
La libertà
Di andarmene
Cioè
E se no
Che gli diano un lavoro
Qualunque lavoro
In teatro
Anche come manovale
Di scena
Se anche questo
Non è possibile
Chiedo al governo
Sovietico
Di fare di me
Quel che ritiene necessario
Ma in qualche modo
Farmi qualcosa
Perché io
Drammaturgo
Autore di cinque drammi
Conosciuto
In unione sovietica
E all'estero
In questo momento
Mi trovo davanti
Solo la povertà
La strada
E la rovina
Questa lettera
È del 28 marzo
E può darsi
Che la risposta
Che riceve
L'avrebbe ricevuta
Comunque
Pare che la cronologia
Dica che in realtà
Stalin ha letto
Questa lettera
Aveva intenzione
Di rispondere positivamente
Già già
Già prima di quello
Che sto per dirvi
Ma quello che sto per dirvi
Sicuramente
Ha cambiato la situazione
La lettera
È del 28 marzo
Il 14 aprile
Si suicida
Ma Iakovski
Il poeta
Della rivoluzione
Più popolare
Che aveva sposato
In pieno
La causa bolshevica
La causa rivoluzionaria
Il poeta
Coccolato
E portato
In palmo di mano
Dal potere
Il protagonista
Della vita
Culturale
Sovietica
Che nel 1930
Si ammazza
Per ragioni private
Ma anche per ragioni
Come dire
Di totale
Perdita di fiducia
In quello che sta succedendo
La morte di Iakovski
È una sola
Fra le morti
I suicidi
Dei poeti
Sono frequenti
In quegli anni
C'è un libro
Famoso
Di un linguista
Sovietico
Romano Jakobson
Che si intitola
Una generazione
Che ha dissipato
I suoi poeti
Al momento
Della rivoluzione
In Russia
C'è una generazione
Di poeti
Straordinari
Tanti di loro
Si sono suicidati
Negli anni successivi
Mi fermo un attimo
Su questa cosa
Del suicidio
Di Ma Iakovski
Perché è molto
Interessante
Di per sé
Al di là dell'impatto
Che secondo me
Ha avuto
Sul destino
Di Bulgakov
Sapete
Ma Iakovski
Scrive
Una lettera
Di commiato
Prima di suicidarsi
Scrive
A tutti
Se muoio
Non incolpate nessuno
E per favore
Niente pettegolezzi
Il defunto
Non li poteva sopportare
Per noi italiani
È una frase importante
Conosceva sicuramente
Questa lettera
Cesare Pavese
Che vent'anni dopo
Si è ucciso
E ha lasciato
Un biglietto
Pavese
In cui scriveva
Perdono a tutti
E a tutti
Chiedo perdono
Va bene?
Non fate troppi
Pettegolezzi
Così Ma Iakovski
Dopo aver scritto
Niente pettegolezzi
Dice
Mamma
Sorelle
Compagni
Perdonatemi
Non è una soluzione
Non la consiglio a nessuno
Ma io non ho altra scelta
Lilia
Amami
Lilia Brick
La sua donna
Compagno governo
La mia famiglia
E Lilia Brick
La mamma
Le mie sorelle
Se farai in modo
Che abbiano
Un'esistenza
Decorosa
Ti ringrazio
Il 14 aprile
Mayakovsky
Si è ucciso
Il 17 aprile
Bulgakov
Va ai funerali
Di Mayakovsky
E il giorno dopo
Succede una di quelle cose
Che ancora oggi
Rendono
L'Unione Sovietica
Un paese
Così difficile da capire
Così surreale
Perché a casa di Bulgakov
Squilla il telefono
Lui faceva la pennichella
Dopo pranzo
Lo svegliano
Dice
C'è Stalin al telefono
E Stalin gli dice
Ma è vero
Che vuole andare all'estero
Dice
Abbiamo ricevuto la sua lettera
L'abbiamo letta
Con i compagni
E riceverà
Una risposta positiva
Ma è proprio vero
Che lei vuole andare all'estero
Non ne può
Proprio più
Di noi
Sono andato a vedere
Si potrebbe anche tradurre
L'abbiamo proprio stufata
Ecco
Bulgakov dice
Ci ho pensato molto
Mi sono chiesto
Se uno scrittore russo
Può vivere lontano
Dalla patria
E ho concluso
Che non può
E Stalin
Ha ragione
Anch'io la penso così
Dov'è che vuole lavorare?
Magari al teatro d'arte?
E dice
Sì volevo
Ma mi hanno rifiutato
Lei gli mandi una richiesta
Ho l'impressione
Che accetteranno
Il giorno dopo
Bulgakov viene assunto
Come aiuto regista
Al teatro d'arte
E allora
Il compagno governo
Non voleva altri suicidi
Questo è evidente
In quel momento
Basta
È bastato
Mayakovsky
Però al tempo stesso
Il fatto che a Stalin
Bulgakov piace
Gli piace moltissimo
E farlo ammazzare
Gli seccherebbe un pochino
E quindi per il momento
Lo facciamo lavorare
E che Stalin
Si sia un po' tormentato
Su questa cosa
Lo sappiamo
Perché chiede anche consiglio
C'è una sua corrispondenza
Con quello che è
Il più famoso
Degli scrittori russi
Ufficiali
Comunisti
Approvati
Maxim Gorky
Grande scrittore
Però scrittore realista
Oggi sembra un po' superato
A rileggerlo oggi
All'epoca famosissimo
In tutto il mondo
Grande sostenitore
Del potere sovietico
C'è una lettera
Di Gorky a Stalin
Qualche mese dopo
In cui Gorky
Dà a Stalin
Il suo parere
Su Bulgakov
E' solo la critica sovietica
Che ha voluto vedere
Nei giorni dei Turbin
Un'opera antisovietica
Gorky ha capito benissimo
Che Stalin vuole
Un rapporto favorevole
Comunque
Poi le cose
Bisogna farle per bene
Bulgakov
Non mi è parente
Non ho nessuna voglia
Di difenderlo
Ma è un letterato
Di talento
E da noi
Non ce ne sono mica tanti
Non è il caso
Di trasformarli
In martiri
Di un'idea
Il nemico
Bisogna
O distruggerlo
O rieducarlo
In questo caso
Io sono
Per la rieducazione
Bulgakov
Si lamenta
Che non ha lavoro
Che non guadagna
E fatelo lavorare
Fatelo guadagnare
E sarà un grande
Incoraggiamento
Per tutti quei letterati
Che non sono
Dei nostri
Ma che però
Possono essere
Come si diceva allora
Dei compagni
Di strada
Si impegneranno
Molto di più
Se vedranno
Questo esempio
Quindi Bulgakov
Lavora
Lavora in teatro
Ma nel frattempo
Scusatemi
Ma noi dobbiamo
Cambiare argomento
Perché
Perché nel frattempo
Bulgakov
Ha cominciato a scrivere
Il suo grande romanzo
Questo romanzo
Che cambierà titolo
Più volte
Che sarà scritto
Riscritto
Bruciato
Di nuovo
E che anche adesso
Circola in versioni
Leggermente diverse
Se andate a vedere
A confrontare
Le traduzioni
A volte c'è un
Qualche pagina
Che manca
Da un'eversione
E oggi si chiama
Il maestro
E Margherita
Io vorrei provare
A dirvi di cosa
Parla il maestro
E Margherita
Ma chi di voi
L'ha letto
Sa che è difficilissimo
Dire di cosa parla
Parla di cosa
Vuol dire
Essere un genio
E scrivere
Un romanzo
Immortale
Ed essere
Perseguitati
Perché il romanzo
Fa paura
E di come
Alla fine
Però
La grandezza
Dell'artista
Trionfa
Sempre
Sull'ottusità
Del potere
Parla di amore
Anzi è un grande
Romanzo d'amore
E parla
Della mosca
Sovietica
Degli anni
20 e 30
Con tutta la sua
Voglia di normalità
Piccolo borghese
Con tutte le meschinità
I carrierismi
Gli arricchimenti
Sospetti
E al tempo stesso
La sensazione
Della tragedia
Incombente
Perché mentre
Ognuno bada
Alla sua carriera
I suoi intrighi
A ottenere
Quel posto
L'aumento
Ogni tanto
Qualcuno
Sparisce
E non se ne sa
Più niente
Il maestro
È
Lo scrittore
Perseguitato
Dal regime
Perché
Sta scrivendo
Un romanzo
Su un argomento
Che non è
Esattamente
Il più adatto
Gesù
E Ponzio Pilato
E Margherita
È la sua donna
È lei
Che l'ha
Soprannominato
Il maestro
E il maestro
Sta scrivendo
Questo grandioso romanzo
Però non lo può finire
Perché
Perché l'hanno mandato
In clinica psichiatrica
Molti capitoli
Del maestro
E Margherita
Sono
I capitoli
Del romanzo
Su Ponzio Pilato
Che il maestro
Sta scrivendo
Quindi
Una prima cosa
Da chiarire
Che in questo romanzo
Ci sono due romanzi
In uno
C'è il romanzo
Di Bulgakov
Che si svolge
A Mosca
E c'è il romanzo
Del maestro
Che si svolge
A Gerusalemme
Sotto il regno
Di Tiberio
E il governo
Di Ponzio Pilato
Ma non ho ancora detto
In realtà
Qual è il protagonista
L'ho detto prima
Va bene
Lo sapete
Il vero protagonista
Del libro
È il diavolo
Che si presenta
A Mosca
Nella Mosca
Sovietica
Con l'idea
Di andare a vedere
Che razzo di posto è
Questa Unione Sovietica
E di giocare
Un po' di scherzi
Tremendi
Ai Moscoviti
E al potere sovietico
Vi racconto
Come comincia il romanzo
Capitolo primo
Titolo del capitolo
Non parlate mai
Con gli sconosciuti
Siamo a Mosca
In un giardino pubblico
Gli stagni
Del patriarca
Siamo in una calda serata
Di primavera
Di maggio
Ci sono
Notate che
Una delle magie
Di questo romanzo
È che si svolge
A Mosca
In una mosca
Vera
Perfettamente riconoscibile
Con tutti gli indirizzi
Quei giardini pubblici
Sono ancora lì
Ci sono due letterati
Che discutono
Su una panchina
I due letterati
Sono
Io lo so benissimo
Che i nomi russi
Terrorizzano tutti
Uno si chiama
Mikhail Aleksandrovich Berlios
È il direttore
Lo chiamerò il direttore
Va bene
È il direttore
Di un'importante rivista letteraria
Il presidente
Di un'importante
Associazione letteraria
Il Massolit
Letteratura per le masse
Un uomo di potere
Dell'ambiente letterario
Il direttore
Il suo interlocutore
È un giovane poeta
Si chiama Ivan Nikolaevich
Panirioff
Ma scrive sotto
Lo pseudonimo
Il senza tetto
È un giovane poeta
Proletario
Di quelli che la rivoluzione
Ha fatto venire fuori
A quintali
Bulgakov
Ovviamente lo sfotte
Senza pietà
Il povero Ivan
Il poeta
È pieno di buone intenzioni
Non ha mai letto
Un libro in vita sua
È ignorantissimo
I due letterati
Stanno discutendo
Perché il direttore
Ha commissionato al poeta
Un grande poema
Antireligioso
Il poema deve essere
Su Gesù
E Ivan
Si è messo al lavoro
E ha scritto
Il poema su Gesù
Ma il direttore
Non è contento
E gli dice
Ivan non hai capito
Certo nel tuo poema
Questo Gesù
Viene fuori
Come un furfante
Un truffatore
Ma tu non hai capito
Non è questo il punto
Noi dobbiamo far vedere
Che Gesù
Non è mai esistito
Invece nel tuo poema
Esiste
Non va bene
Lo devi rifare
Mentre sono lì
Che discutono
Compare
Nei giardinetti
Un distinto
Forestiero
È molto alto
Molto ben vestito
Si vede subito
Che non è russo
Anche se non si capisce bene
Dire che nazionalità sia
Lo vedono arrivare
Il direttore dice
Un polacco
E là il poetrice
Un inglese
Arriva questo forestiero
Distintissimo
Si aggira per un po'
Poi
Poi si siede
Sulla loro panchina
E fa
Scusatemi eh
Ma non ho potuto fare a meno
Di ascoltare
La vostra conversazione
Interessantissima
Ho sentito che dite
Che Gesù non è esistito
Ma scusatemi eh
Ma ho capito bene
Loro non credono in Dio
Mi dice no
Dice il direttore
Ma non c'è mica niente di strano
Certo che non ci crediamo
Ma ma ma allora
Ma allora
Loro sono atei
Non lo dirò a nessuno
E Dio dice
Ma si figuri un po'
Nel nostro paese
È da tanto tempo
Che il popolo
Ha smesso di credere
A queste fanfaluche
Non c'è mica niente di strano
Ma ma scusate
Dice il distinto forestiero
Dice ma allora
Le prove dell'esistenza di Dio
Che sono esattamente cinque
Come è noto
Anzi poi
Kant
Ne ha formulata anche una sesta
A questo punto
Il giovane poeta
Che ha ascoltato stupefatto
Se ne esce
E sbotta
Questo Kant
Bisognerebbe sbatterlo
Un paio d'anni
In campo di concentramento
Il direttore ovviamente
Arrossisce i vanno
Il distinto forestiero
Si mette a ridere
Proprio così
Sono d'accordo anch'io
Glielo dicevo proprio
L'altro giorno
A Kant
A pranzo
Mi scusi professore
Ma quella sua prova
Dell'esistenza di Dio
È un'assurdità
Le rideranno dietro
Quanto al mandarlo
In campo di concentramento
Dice il forestiero
Se lo meriterebbe
Sono d'accordo anch'io
Ma purtroppo è impossibile
Perché da più di cent'anni
Il professor Kant
Si trova in un luogo
Molto più lontano
Da cui è assolutamente
Impossibile
Tirarlo fuori
A questo punto
Il direttore
Comincia a sospettare
Di avere a che fare
Con un pazzo
E l'altro
Tranquillamente va avanti
Ma scusate allora
Se voi pensate
Che Dio non esista
Ma allora
Chi dirige
La vita sulla terra?
L'uomo
Dirige la vita sulla terra
Dice il forestiero
Ma scusate
Ma l'uomo
Uno che non sa neanche
Cosa farà stasera
Il direttore
Prende gusto
Alla discussione
Ma abbia pazienza
Io so benissimo
Cosa farò stasera
Vabbè certo
Se mi cade
Una tegola in testa
Mentre torno a casa
No
Dice il forestiero
Non le cadrà
Una tegola in testa
Lei morirà
Di un'altra morte
Già
E lei sa anche quale
Per caso?
Dice così
Aspetti un attimo
Faccio due calcoli
Saturno
Venere
Orione
Sì certo
Le taglieranno la testa
Il direttore comincia
A essere un po' preoccupato
Però comunque
Continua a tenere testa
Dice
Ma chi scusi
Mi taglierà la testa
Nemici?
Invasori?
Dice no
Una ragazza russa
Membro della gioventù comunista
Abbia pazienza
Dice il direttore
Ma mi sembra
Mi sembra poco probabile
E in ogni caso
Lei ha un bel dire
Ma io so perfettamente
Cosa farò stasera
Adesso faccio un salto a casa
Poi alle dieci
C'è una riunione
Del massolite
Io presiedo
Dice no
Dice il forestiero
Mi spiace
È assolutamente impossibile
La riunione
Non si terrà
Perché non si terrà?
A questo punto
Il forestiero
Dice una cosa
Che convince
Definitivamente
Il direttore Berlioz
Che ha a che fare
Con un pazzo
Perché il forestiero
Dice
No no
La riunione
Non si terrà
Perché
Annushka
Ha già comprato
L'olio di girasole
E l'ho anche già versato
E quindi
Mi dispiace
Ma la riunione
Non avrà luogo
A questo punto
Il direttore
E il poeta
Chiedono congedo
Per un altro
Scusi eh
Dovremmo dirci una cosa
Prego prego
Ma Ivan
Ma secondo te è pazzo?
No no
Secondo me non è pazzo
È una spia straniera
Anzi
Non è neanche una spia straniera
Hai sentito come parla russo?
Dice ma in certi momenti
Ha un accento straniero
Sì ma in altri momenti
Lo parla perfettamente
Guarda che è un emigrato
Dobbiamo denunciarlo
Bisogna telefonare
Sì sì hai ragione
Hai ragione
Però andiamo un po' a vedere
Appena tornano alla panchina
Il forestiero dice
Ah scusate eh
Posso capire che abbiate dei sospetti
Non mi sono presentato
C'è questo c'è ascoltato
Ho sentito tutto
E non mi sono presentato
Abbiate pazienza
Tira fuori un biglietto da visita
Intestato al professor Voland
Dice io sono un esperto di magia nera
Sono stato convocato a Mosca
Per esaminare certi manoscritti medievali
Vedete che il medioevo viene sempre fuori
Comunque in un modo o nell'altro
E i due
Accidenti
Capito allora
Poi c'è questa battuta
Che io trovo meravigliosa
In cui il direttore gli dice
Ma lei è tedesco?
E il forestiero dice
Ci penso
Sì sì direi tedesco
E dopodiché
Si china all'orecchio dei due
E gli fa comunque
Tengano presente
Che Gesù
È esistito
Dice ma scusi
Abbia pazienza
È facile dirlo così
Ci vogliono delle prove
E neanche di prove
C'è nessun bisogno
Ve lo racconto io
Come è andata
E comincia il secondo capitolo
Del romanzo
Che racconta di Ponzio Pilato
Che si prepara nel suo palazzo
A giudicare un agitatore
L'intero secondo capitolo
Del maestro e Margherita
È il racconto di Ponzio Pilato
È come se fosse un capitolo
Del romanzo del maestro
Il maestro non è ancora comparso
Però questo è già lì
Ed è il
Il professor Voland
Che avete già capito
Chi è ovviamente
Il diavolo in incognito
Probabilmente tedesco
Dovendo scegliere
Che racconta questa storia
E poi finisce il capitolo
I due letterati si accorrono
Che ormai è buio
Sono rimasti lì
Chissà quanto tempo
A sentire questa storia
Guarda come ci ha impappocchiati
No no
Adesso basta però
E il direttore gli fa
Ma professore
Bellissima storia
Ma lei come fa a saperla
Questa storia?
Ah io c'ero
Io ci sono sempre
Non mi vedevano
Ma c'ero
Proprio lì sul balcone
Di Ponzio Pilato
C'è no no
È pazzo
Ivan è pazzo
Vado a telefonare
Professore scusi
Devo andare via un secondo
Lei intanto però mi dica
Dove alloggia?
Alloggi in albergo vero?
Dice no
Dice il forestiero
Veramente pensavo
Di alloggiare a casa sua
Come scusi a casa mia?
Io volentieri eh
Volentieri ma non starà
Tanto comodo
Abbia pazienza
Io le consiglio un albergo
Comunque scusi eh
Che devo andare un attimo
A telefonare
Parte
Va a telefonare
Esce dai giardinetti
Mette la mano sul cancelletto
Fuori ci sono i binari
Del tram
Apri il cancelletto
Arriva il tram
Guidato da una ragazza
Del gioventù comunista
Con tanto rifazzoletto rosso
Al collo
Arriva il tram
Il direttore Berlioz
Prudentemente fa un passo indietro
Qualcuno ha versato
Dell'olio di girasole
Per terra
Scivola
Paf
Precipita sui binari
Arriva il tram
Tutti urlano
Annusca guarda
Cos'hai combinato
Che hai versato l'olio
E un attimo dopo
La testa tagliata
Del direttore
Rotola
In mezzo
Ai giardinetti
E mentre
Il poeta
Ivan Nikolaevich
Alias
Il senza tetto
Finisce direttamente
In clinica
Psichiatrica
Dove incontrerà
Qualcuno
Naturalmente
Voland
Lo chiameremo anche noi così
Prende possesso
Dell'appartamento
Del defunto
Prende possesso
Dell'appartamento
Numero 50
Sapete che in Russia
Anche gli appartamenti
Hanno i numeri
Non soltanto la casa
Il portone
Ma anche gli appartamenti
L'appartamento
Numero 50
Al 302 bis
Della via Sadovaia
Un grande viale
Di Mosca
Il numero 302 bis
In realtà non esiste
Sulla Sadovaia
Qualcuno ha anche notato
Che bis
In ucraino
Vuol dire diavolo
Però l'appartamento 50
Esiste a un altro numero
Della Sadovaia
Ci abitava Bulgakov
Bulgakov
Abitava
Nell'appartamento
Numero 50
Al numero 10
Della Sadovaia
A due isolati
Dagli stagni
Del patriarca
Dai giardinetti
E in quell'appartamento
Ambienta
Come dire
Il diavolo
Che prende possesso
Con tutta una serie di aiutanti
Ve li dico fin d'ora
Sì
Il buffone
Karaviov
L'assassino
Azzazello
La strega
Hella
Con una gran cicatrice
Sul collo
E che va in giro
Sempre nuda
E il gatto gigante
E parlante
Behemoth
Che in russo
Vuol dire
Ippopotamo
Un gatto
Un gatto grande
Come un maiale
Che cammina
E retto
E parla
Con molto buon senso
Si sistemano tutti
In questo alloggio
E qui c'è da dire
Una cosa
Che è indicativa
Dello status
Straordinario
Che avevano
Non so se ce l'hanno ancora
Ma che avevano
In Russia
Gli scrittori
Quando il romanzo
Di Bulgakov
Molti anni dopo la sua morte
Viene pubblicato
In Unione Sovietica
Negli anni 60
L'appartamento
Numero 50
Diventa di colpo
Celeberrimo
E la gente
Va lì
Con grande scandalo
Degli inquilini
A scrivere sui muri
Oggi lo hanno ripulito
Ma ci sono le fotografie
Io ho visto
Delle fotografie
Di com'era
Questo alloggio
Qualche decennio fa
Tutto l'ingresso
L'androne
Le scale
Tutti pieni
Di graffiti
Di gente
Che era venuta
In pellegrinaggio
All'appartamento
Numero 50
Già nell'androne
C'era una scritta
Colossale
Di qualcuno
Che era arrivato
Con la bomboletta
Aveva scritto
Gloria Bulgakov
E
Sulla scala
C'era uno
Che aveva scritto
La frase
Con cui Voland
Si rivolge
Ai due letterati
Sulla panchina
Ma voi siete atei
E sotto la risposta
No
Non siamo atei
C'è stata anche
Una ragazza
Che ha scritto
Anche se non sono
Margherita
Troverò il mio maestro
Oggi appunto
È diventato
Tutto un museo
È un po' diverso
Ma ne parleremo ancora
Alla fine
Questo è il romanzo
Che Bulgakov
Comincia a scrivere
Alla fine degli anni 20
E che continua
A scrivere
Per anni
Sapendo benissimo
Che pubblicarlo
È assolutamente
Improbabile
E tuttavia
E anche perché
È un perfezionista
Che instancabilmente
Aggiusta
Cambia
Modifica
Aggiunge
E poi
Ha dei momenti
Di panico
In quel momento
Di disperazione
Nel 1930
Erano già tre anni
Che lo scriveva
Quando scrive al governo
Dicendo
Lasciatemi andar via
In un momento
In un momento di disperazione
Bulgakov
Brucia
Nella stufa
Il manoscritto
Del romanzo
Che in quel momento
Non si chiama ancora
Il maestro è Margherita
Lui lo chiamava
Il mio romanzo
Sul diavolo
E anzi
Il personaggio di Margherita
Non c'è ancora neanche
Nella prima stesura
Compare dopo
Perché
Dopo aver bruciato
Il romanzo
Nel 30
Bulgakov
Ricomincia a scriverlo
Due anni dopo
Dopo che nel frattempo
Si è innamorato
Un'altra volta
E si è sposato
Per la terza volta
Ha divorziato
Da Liubov
E ha sposato
Jelena
Jelena Shilovskaya
Che è Margherita
E la Margherita
Del romanzo
E una donna
Anche lei
Non più giovane
Una donna
Quando si conoscono
Nel 29
Lei ha già 36 anni
E sposata
Con due matrimoni
Alle spalle
Figlia di un ebreo
Battezzato
La madre
Era figlia
Di un prete ortodosso
Jelena
Aveva sposato
Un ufficiale
Dell'armata rossa
Durante la guerra civile
Poi si era messa
Con il comandante
Di suo marito
Aveva divorziato
Dal marito
Sposato il comandante
Il comandante
È diventato
Generale
Negli anni 30
Ielen
I primi anni 30
Quando si innamorano
Con Bulgakov
Lei è la moglie
Infelice
Di un importante
Generale
E loro
Cominciano
Una relazione
Segreta
Poi il generale
Scopre tutto
C'è tutta la corrispondenza
Il generale
Lo scopre
Scrive a Bulgakov
Giovanotto
Venga che dobbiamo
Parlare
Lo convoca
Gli impone
Di smettere
Questa cosa
Bulgakov
E Jelena
Accettano
Per un anno
Non si vedono più
Poi si incontrano
Ancora
Capiscono
Che in realtà
Si amano
A questo punto
Jelena
Molle il generale
Se ne va di casa
Con i figli
Di dieci
E di cinque anni
Va a vivere
Con Bulgakov
Bulgakov
Scrive una bellissima
Lecce
Tutto in internet
Scrive una lettera
Al generale
Dicendo
Per la felicità
Di Jelena
Compia un nobile gesto
Il generale
Scrive
Lo faccio solo
Per Jelena
Non per te
Che sia ben chiaro
Comunque
Il generale
Fa un passo indietro
Divorziano
Lui si tiene
Il figlio maggiore
E Jelena
Col figlio piccolo
Va a vivere
Con Bulgakov
Che divorzia
Dalla seconda moglie
E il giorno dopo
Sposa Jelena
In Unione Sovietica
Era assai facile
Sia divorziare
Sia sposarsi
Non è che ci vuole
Se tanta burocrazia
E Jelena
Che anche lei
È sopravvissuta
Bulgakov
Naturalmente
Di un sacco di anni
Jelena ricorda
Che durante il viaggio
Di nozze
A Leningrado
Suo marito
Le confessa
Che ha questa cosa
Che lo angoscia
Che aveva cominciato
A scrivere un romanzo
A cui teneva
Infinitamente
E poi
L'aveva bruciato
Però
Però adesso
Che ci sei tu
Mi è venuta voglia
Di riprenderlo
Anzi lo farò
E dice Jelena
Eravamo in albergo
A Leningrado
Si è seduto
Si è messo a riscriverlo
Gli ho chiesto
Ma scusa
Dice me lo ricordo
Tutto a memoria
Salvo che nel romanzo
Irrompe
Il nuovo personaggio
Di Margherita
Il maestro
Lo scrittore
Perseguitato
Finito in manicomio
Col suo romanzo
Che in un momento
Di disperazione
Ha bruciato
Vive con questa donna
Una donna infelice
Sposata male
Ricca
Ma infelice
Hanno una relazione
Lui vive in uno scantinato
Lei va a trovarlo
Tutti i giorni
Gli cucina
Sono felici
A loro modo
E poi
E poi il maestro
È sparito
Che in clinica
Psichiatrica
Lo sappiamo noi
Ma non lo sa Margherita
Lei sa solo
Che
Che il suo amante
È sparito
E a questo punto
Avendo costruito
Questa trama
Bulgakov
Riesce a farla
Incontrare
Con la storia
Di Voland
Del diavolo
In missione
A Mosca
Il quale compie
Nel frattempo
Ha fatto un'infinità
Di cose divertentissime
Che non sto a raccontarvi
Le leggerete
Nel romanzo
Ma a un certo momento
Le due trame
Si incrociano
Perché il momento
Culminante
Del soggiorno
Di Voland
A Mosca
Consisterà
In un grande
Ballo
Notturno
Che darà
Per un'infinità
Di morti
Di dannati
Di gente
Che uscirà
Dall'inferno
Per partecipare
A questo ballo
E per tradizione
Ci deve essere
Una strega
Che faccia
Da regina
Del ballo
Al braccio
Del diavolo
A ricevere
Per tutta la
Notte
Questa moltitudine
Di dannati
Che si accalcheranno
Per renderle omaggio
E il diavolo
Fa cercare
Per Mosca
Una strega
E uno
Dei suoi
Adepti
Gli segnala
Margherita
E quindi
Un giorno
Margherita
Disperata
Che sta pensando
Di buttarsi
Nel fiume
Perché il suo
Matrimonio
È infelice
E il suo amante
È sparito
Margherita
Si vede
Contattare
Da un tipo
Assai sinistro
Che a nome
Di un ricco
Straniero
Le fa
Una strana
Proposta
Prima a un certo punto
Margherita
Pensa che vogliono
Portarsela a letto
Diceva
Sono pronta a tutto
Ormai
Poi
No niente di tutto questo
Noi vogliamo
Soltanto trasformarla
In una strega
E dovrà
Partecipare
Al grande ballo
Al fianco
Del nostro padrone
E Margherita
Diceva
Vabbè
Tanto peggio di così
Non mi può andare
Fatemi sapere
Cosa devo fare
Dice niente
Si deve spalmare
Stanotte
C'è la luna piena
Vero?
Perfetto
Stanotte si mette
Nuda
Si spalma
Questa crema
Su tutto il corpo
Poi vedrà
Margherita
Esegue
E diventa
Una strega
Capace di volare
Sulla scopa
Tutta una serie
Di avventure
Di Margherita
Che vola
Nel cielo di mosca
Sulla scopa
Nuda
E poi finalmente
Approda
All'appartamento
Numero 50
Che nel frattempo
È diventato
Un immenso palazzo
Sotterraneo
Pieno di saloni
Dove un'infinità
Di esseri spettrali
Ballano
E via via
Che arrivano
Ecco Voland
Se la tiene accanto
Nuda
E tutti quelli
Che arrivano
Si inchinano davanti a lei
Le baciano il ginocchio
C'è tutta una sfilata
Di grandi criminali
Del passato
E della storia russa
E anche criminali comuni
Margherita viene colpita
In particolare
Da un personaggio
È una ragazza
Che si chiama Frida
È una dannata
È dannata
Perché ha ammazzato
Il suo bambino
Oh
Tenete presente
Fra le mille chiavi
Di lettura
Di questo romanzo
Complicatissimo
C'è una serie di ecchi
Del faust
Naturalmente
Di Goethe
A partire dal nome
Margherita
E la Gretchen
La Margherita
Del faust
Uccide il suo bambino
Per l'appunto
Qui è questa Frida
Che ha ucciso
Il suo bambino
E vive all'inferno
Una vita spaventosa
Perché lei
L'ha strangolato
L'ha soffocato
Con un fazzoletto
E ogni giorno
Le portano
Il fazzoletto
Con cui lei
Ha ucciso
Il suo bambino
E Frida
È talmente sofferente
Che quando si inginocchia
Davanti alla regina
La implora
Di aiutarla
E Margherita
Si lascia prendere
Dal dolore
Di questa ragazza
E le dice
Imprudentemente
Va bene Frida
Cercherò di fare
Qualcosa per te
Poi passa
Passa tutta la serata
Passa tutta la notte
E finalmente
Finalmente
La festa è finita
Spariscono tutti
Si ritrovano
Intorno a un tavolo
A bere
L'ultimo bicchiere
Voland
Il gatto parlante
I suoi aiutanti
Diabolici
E Margherita
Si accorta
All'improvviso
Di essere nuda
Le hanno messo addosso
Un mantello
È lì
E pensa
Vabbè adesso
Adesso vado a buttarmi
Nel fiume
Cos'altro vuoi che faccia
Si alza
Dice
Vado allora
Ah notate
Che le avevano promesso
Una ricompensa
Scusate
Mi dimentico i pezzi
Le avevano promesso
Una ricompensa
Di esaudire un desiderio
E anche per quello
Che lei è andata
Però nessuno dice niente
Margherita dice
Va bene
Vado a buttarmi nel fiume
Si alza e dice
È stato un onore
È stato un piacere
Vado
A questo punto
Voland
Le dice
No un momento
Si sieda
Donna orgogliosa
Noi volevamo
Metterla alla prova
E lei l'ha superata
Non chieda mai niente
Specialmente a quelli
Che sono più forti di lei
Ci penseranno loro
A offrire
E le daranno
Tutto
Allora
Cosa vuole
Margherita
Margherita è lì
Perché all'inizio
Si era detta
Voglio che mi restituiscano
Il mio amante
Voglio che mi ridiano
Il maestro
Però in quel momento
Di colpo
Le viene in mente
Frida
E il fatto che
Frida ha promesso
E allora
Allora è lì
E Voland insiste
Allora
Su
Chieda
Sicché dunque
Posso chiedere una cosa?
Esigere
Donna mia
Rispose Voland
Esigere
Una cosa
Come Voland
Ripetendo le parole stesse
Di Margherita
Aveva sottolineato abilmente
E chiaramente
Una
Cosa
Margherita
Sospirò ancora una volta
E disse
Voglio che smettano
Di porgere a Frida
Il fazzoletto
Col quale
Essa
Soffocò
Il suo bambino
Il gatto
Alzò gli occhi
Al cielo
Dato che
Prese a dire
Voland
Sogghignando
E del tutto
Esclusa
La possibilità
Che lei
Abbia ricevuto
Una bustarella
Da quella
Stupida
Di Frida
Non so proprio
Che fare
Rimane forse
Una cosa sola
Procurarsi
Degli stracci
E tappare
Tutte le fessure
Della mia camera
Da letto
Esattamente come voi
Margherita
Non capisce
Che cosa diavolo
Stia dicendo
Cos'è sta storia?
Di cosa sta parlando?
Sto parlando
Della pietà
Spiego
Voland
Senza staccare
Da Margherita
Il suo occhio
Infuocato
Talvolta
Essa
La pietà
Si insinua
Del tutto
Inattesa
E insidiosa
Nelle fessure
Più anguste
Perciò
Sto parlando
Di stracci
E poi continua
Ma lei
Mi scusi
È una persona
Eccezionale?
Di una bontà
Straordinaria?
No
Dice Margherita
Io
Non voglio mica
Vantarmi
Io sono una poveretta
Però ho promesso
A Frida
Non potevo fare
Diversamente
Ah
Disse Voland
Ora capisco
E lo farà
Domandò
Sottovoce Margherita
Nemmeno per idea
Rispose Voland
Il fatto è
Cara regina
Che c'è stata
Una piccola confusione
Ogni di Castero
Deve occuparsi
Dei propri affari
Che senso c'è
A fare qualcosa
Che è di competenza
Di un altro
Chiamiamolo così
Ministero
Perciò
Io non lo farò
E lo farà
Lei stessa
Ma si farà
Come voglio io
Mentre tutti
Io vi leggo
Dei pezzetti
Intanto c'è tutta
La corte del diavolo
Che ascolta
Soghigna
Fanno occhiataccia
E alzano gli occhi al cielo
Per tutta questa pantomima
Però alla fine
Alla fine
Si farà come voglio io
Avanti
Lo faccia
Uffa
Che tormento
Brontolo Voland
Perché si volta
Dall'altra parte
Facendo finta
Di non esserci
Dunque
Frida
Suggerì Karaviov
Gridò Margherita
Con voce acuta
Lucio si spalancò
E una donna
Scarmigliata
Nuda
Ma che non dava
Più segno alcuno
Di essere ubriaca
Irruppe nella stanza
Con occhi disperati
E protese
Le due mani
Verso Margherita
La quale disse
Maestosamente
Sei perdonata
Non ti porgeranno
Più il fazzoletto
Frida
Cade in ginocchio
Poi la portano via
Margherita si alza
La ringrazio
Addio
Beh
Che ne pensi
Beh mot
Disse Voland
Non vogliamo lucrare
Sul gesto
Di una persona
Poco pratica
In una notte di festa
Si volse
Verso Margherita
Dunque
Questo non conta
Perché io
Non ho fatto niente
Che cosa vuole
Per sé
Qui c'è un attimo
Di silenzio
Uno degli aiutanti
Di Voland
Si china
All'orecchio
Di Margherita
Le fa
Io stavolta
Le consiglierei
Di essere
Un po' più pratica
Perché non è detto
Che la fortuna
Duri per sempre
Voglio che subito
In quest'attimo stesso
Mi venga restituito
Il mio amante
Il maestro
Disse Margherita
E uno spasimo
Le contrasse il viso
Allora una folata
Di vento
Irruppe nella stanza
La fiamma
Delle candele
Nei candelabri
Si spese
Eccetera
E nel vano
Della finestra
Compara il maestro
Ancora col camicione
Dell'ospedale
Psichiatrico
Portato lì di peso
Segue lunga scena
Agnizione
Riconoscimento
Gioia
Però però il maestro
Però il maestro
È pieno di angoscia
Il maestro
È pieno di sofferenza
Ed è pieno di sofferenza
Perché
Perché appunto
Non solo esce
Da questa esperienza
Traumatica
Della clinica psichiatrica
Però la sua vera angoscia
È che ha distrutto
Il suo romanzo
Ha distrutto
Che è il motivo
Per cui Margherita
Lo chiamava
Il maestro
Perché Margherita
In quel romanzo
Aveva riconosciuto qualcosa
Che raccontava
Ponzio Pilato
Appunto
E allora
Il maestro
È triste
Cupo
E Margherita
È tristissima
Anche lei
E Voland
Tutto delusi
Ma che cosa avete
Insomma
Com'è che non siete contenti
E no
Margherita spiega
Margherita guardi
Anzi no
Il maestro
Dice no
È che io avevo scritto
Un romanzo
Cosa vuole
E Margherita
Si era fatta
Chissà quale idea
Di questo romanzo
E Voland
Dice
Ma
Un romanzo
Interessante
Su cosa
Dice su Ponzio Pilato
Voland si mette a sghignazzare
Ma che razza di argomento
Ma non poteva
Trovarne un altro
Scusi
Ma che roba
Su me lo faccia un po' vedere
Io purtroppo
Non posso farlo
Rispose il maestro
Perché l'ho bruciato
Nella stufa
Scusi
Non ci credo
Replicò Voland
Non può essere
I manoscritti
Non bruciano
Si voltò verso Behemoth
E disse
Su Behemoth
Dammi qua il romanzo
Il gatto
All'istante
Saltò giù
Dalla seggiola
E tutti
Videro che era seduto
Su un grosso pacco
Di manoscritti
Con un inchino
Il gatto
Porse a Voland
L'esemplare
Che stava
Sopra gli altri
Margherita
Si mise a tremare
E gridò
Commuovendosi
Di nuovo
Fino alle lacrime
Eccolo
Il manoscritto
Si precipitò
Verso Voland
E aggiunse
Rapita
Onnipotente
I manoscritti
Non bruciano
E forse
La frase più famosa
Della letteratura russa
Del novecento
Ed è diventata
Il simbolo appunto
Della resistenza
Dello spirito
Contro la dittatura
E fra l'altro
Come dire
Quando sono stati aperti
Gli archivi del Cagebè
Si è rivelata
Vera
Alla lettera
Perché negli archivi
Del Cagebè
Sono stati ritrovati
Appunto
Il diario di Bulgakov
Come vi dicevo prima
E i manoscritti
Le poesie
Le testimonianze
Di un'infinità
Di autori
Testi che si credeva
Fossero spariti
Per sempre
E invece
Quelli della polizia politica
Avevano tenuto tutto
Era tutto lì
I manoscritti
Non bruciano
E tra l'altro
È il titolo
Di un grande libro
Di uno scrittore russo
Vitaly Shentalinsky
Che appunto
È il primo
Che con una commissione
È entrato
Negli anni 90
Negli archivi
Della Lubianca
Del palazzo
Del Cagebè
A caccia appunto
Dei manoscritti
Dei poeti
E degli scrittori
Scomparsi
Ci sono
Nel palazzo
Della Lubianca
Anche le relazioni
Di quelli
Della polizia segreta
Che intanto
Aveva cambiato nome
Adesso si chiamava
Enkavedè
Di quelli
Che spiavano Bulgakov
Perché il potere sovietico
Continuava a considerare
Gli scrittori
Tutti
Persone
Incredibilmente
Importanti
E incredibilmente
Pericolose
E tutti
Erano sorvegliati
E Bulgakov
Era come mille altri
Continuamente
Seguito
Osservato
Spiato
Da agenti
Che poi facevano
Rapporto
23 maggio
Bulgakov
Soffre di un
Disturbo nervoso
Dice di non poter
Andare da solo
Per strada
Viene accompagnato
Persino di giorno
Lavora molto
Ci sono funzionari
Della polizia politica
Che nei loro rapporti
Raccontano
Di aver addirittura
Chiacchierato
Con Bulgakov
Il quale sa benissimo
Chi sono
E di avergli consigliato
Di stare attento
Bulgakov
Non scrivere più niente
Occupati di altre cose
Ricordati
Della tua professione
Di medico
E cura la gente
E noi
Ti lasceremo
Tranquillo
Perché il fatto è
Che nonostante
Gli interventi
Di Stalin
Bulgakov
Sì
Lavora
Non muore di fame
Lavora in teatro
Fa aiuto regista
Mette in scena
Delle cose
Però le sue cose
Non le pubblicano
Continua a scrivere
A Stalin
E Stalin
Non gli risponde più
Nella famosa telefonata
Stalin aveva detto
Dobbiamo vederci
Bisogna che parliamo
E Bulgakov
Aveva risposto
Certo
Iosif
Vissariorovic
Certo
Non si sono mai visti
Non l'hanno mai chiamato
Al Cremlino
Nel 36
Finalmente
Gli mettono in scena
Un dramma
Sulla vita di Molière
La stampa
Lo stronca
Un dramma reazionario
Inutile
Disperato
Bulgakov
Fa qualcosa
Di cui avrebbe potuto
Vergognarsi
In un altro contesto
Lo faranno anche altri
Decide di scrivere
Un'opera
In lode di Stalin
Stalin aveva avuto
Un suo ruolo
Nella guerra civile
Minore
Ma sotto il governo
Di Stalin
Invece
La sua partecipazione
Nella guerra civile
E la rivoluzione
Era stata ingigantita
Fino a farne
Il protagonista
Nella rivoluzione
Al fianco di Lenin
Aveva prestato servizio
Nel Caucaso
A Batum
Stalin
E Bulgakov
Scrive un dramma
Batum
In cui mostra
Stalin
Appunto
Eroe
Della guerra civile
Stalin
Lo legge
Fa sapere
Che è bello
Ma che non è opportuno
Metterlo in scena
E intanto
Bulgakov
E' malato
Di una malattia renale
Di cui è morto
Suo padre
Tanti anni prima
E' talmente malato
Che nel 39
Si risolve
A scrivere di nuovo
Per chiedere
Che lo lasciano andare
All'estero
Per curarsi
Però siamo nel 39
Ormai
Il mondo sta sprofondando
Nella guerra
Non gli danno il permesso
Ma intanto
Ha finito
Il maestro
E' Margherita
C'è una lettera
Di cui
Di cui sa benissimo
Che non sarà pubblicato
Tanto presto
E forse mai
Una lettera
Alla moglie
A Yelena
Del 15 giugno
Del 38
Ho davanti a me
327 pagine
Del manoscritto
Resta da fare
La cosa più importante
Rileggere
Correggere
E sarà dura
Dovrò stare attento
Ai dettagli
Forse anche
Riscrivere
Qualche parte
Ma che futuro ha?
Mi chiedi
Non lo so
Magari
Ficcherai il manoscritto
In un cassetto
Vicino ai miei drammi
Vietati
E ogni tanto
Ti capiterà
Di pensarci
Ma poi
Chi lo conosce
Il futuro
Forse è davvero meglio
Farlo sparire
In fondo
A qualche baule
Lavora
Corregge
Il 14 maggio
Del 39
Raduna in casa
Gli amici più intimi
E legge
Il romanzo
Da cima a fondo
Trent'anni dopo
Yelena ricorda
Quella notte
Quando ha finito
Di leggere
Ha detto
Bene
Domani lo porto
In casa editrice
Nessuno
Ha detto
Niente
Nel suo diario
Questa era una testimonianza
Successiva
Nel suo diario
Di quella notte
Yelena scrive
Sono rimasti
Tutti paralizzati
Avevano paura
Di tutto
Poi alla porta
Qualcuno
Terrorizzato
Ha cercato
Di spiegarmi
Che cercare
Di pubblicare
Il romanzo
Provocherebbe
Conseguenze
Terribili
Il romanzo
Non viene pubblicato
E nel 1940
Mikhail Afanasyevich
Bulgakov
Muore
Della sua malattia
Renale
Non aveva neanche
50 anni
Suo padre
Era morto
Della stessa malattia
Alla stessa età
Il giorno
Della morte
Di Bulgakov
Squilla il telefono
In casa sua
E il segretario
Di Stalin
Dice
Ma
Il compagno
Bulgakov
È morto?
La moglie
Sì è morto
Dall'altra parte
Riattaccano
Aveva fatto
In tempo
A finire
Il suo romanzo
Sul diavolo
Come lo chiamava
Diversamente
Da tanti altri
Aveva sopravvissuto
Agli anni peggiori
Del terrore di Stalin
Non ha visto
La seconda guerra mondiale
L'operazione barbarossa
L'invasione tedesca
Quando un altro diavolo
È arrivato davvero
Fin quasi a Mosca
E non ha mai saputo
Che il suo romanzo
Negli anni sessanta
È stato accolto
In tutto il mondo
Con commozione
E Eugenio Montale
Disse
Un miracolo
Però
L'aveva profetizzato
Perché il maestro
Margherita
Parla proprio di questo
Del fatto che i romanzi
Non bruciano
E poi tornano fuori
Bulgakov
È sepolto a Mosca
Al cimitero
Di Novo Dievici
E oggi ci sono
Due musei Bulgakov
A Mosca
Tutti e due
Al numero Dieci
Della Sadovaia
Uno al pian terreno
E uno al quarto piano
Nell'appartamento
Numero Cinquanta
In concorrenza
Fra loro
Perché uno è privato
E l'altro è statale
E qualche anno fa
Un inquilino del palazzo
Ha fatto irruzione
Nell'appartamento
E ha cercato
Di devastare
Il museo
Sostenendo
Che lì abitava
Ancora Satana
E che bisognava esorcizzarlo
E c'è un museo Bulgakov
A Kiev
Nella casa
In cui la famiglia
Di Bulgakov
Ha abitato
Da 1906
A 1919
Che è la casa
In cui è ambientato
Il suo dramma
I giorni dei Turbin
Due paesi
Che oggi sono in guerra
L'uno contro l'altro
E i cui governi
Si denunciano a vicenda
Come criminali
E che onorano
Tutti e due
E lo stesso scrittore
E lo sentono
Tutti e due
Come una gloria patria
Applausi
Grazie a tutti
Buonasera
E a domani
Allora
Applausi
Additi